for decades the subway has been the way
to commute in New York City 54% of
residents use it every day but as
ridership increases so have the delays
and fares so we wondered is the subway
still the best way to get to work
today we're following five Queens
residents as they each take different
modes of transit to commute from Long
Island City to Manhattan's financial
district will rate each modes
performance on five metrics time cost
reliability comfort and available app
here we go
Subban
you
to them
so how did everyone do the ferry is
beautiful and relaxing but it's limited
schedule speed and number of stops keep
it from being a serious contender for
now the taxi was cheaper than uber but
it suffers from a lack of apps which is
especially problematic in the outer
boroughs uber was fast comfortable and
had the best app but it loses points for
being the most expensive if successful
the new uber pool option could change
that so it comes down to the bicycle and
subway at first glance the bike appears
to have the win it was the fastest and
cheapest in our test ultimately though
whether distance and physical demand
keep it from being a reliable everyday
mode of transit for most people so
overall the subway is still the best
option but it will need to modernize and
secure funding to keep up with demand or
risk being left behind by better faster
choices